[Applaudissements]
marcel béliveau surprise sur prise est
bien ce qu on a fait la même chose mais
sûrement les moyens et sans scénario
voici gag sur gages devenu shelby ce
sens bien je le sens bien ce grand gars
venu dans ce nouveau numéro de gags sur
gags aujourd'hui nous allons piéger un
restaurant asiatique avec la complicité
de régis bonjour ça serait pour des
pénale arrabiata nom de pénal arrabiata
à ses côtés c'était une caméra cachée
bravo à tous ces points d'accès regard
la casse tête
merci direction maintenant elle salon de
coiffure une baguette pas trop cuite si
vous avez bravo c'était très attaché
qui d'autre a gagné c'était une caméra
cachée
[Applaudissements]
une autre partie de twilight continue je
vais prendre un bon coup s'il vous plaît
aux [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est les 20000
s'élève à 1000 c les mobiles la cacher
bravo bravo vous rendez vous arrivez
tout d'abord devant la guinguette cette
clinique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au revoir à notre avis mr murray ça
coûte pas cher et on donnera londres et
ses tâches piste à l'autre